how people learn is so important if you
know when I'm in Japan and I go to the
bookstore and they've got you know rows
and rows of books with all the words you
need to learn for toeic or TOEFL that's
very discouraging because we all know
that if we learn a list of words we're
only going to forget them so so there's
nothing there it's just so you spend
hours reviewing a list of words and
they're gone because we know that you
have to meet these words so often in so
many different contexts before they
become part of you if on the other hand
the person can find it could be Harry
Potter it could be Downton Abbey it
could be cheers it could be you know
something on Netflix it could be
anything a podcast and there's just an
abundance of could be listening to you
uh and and if they like your voice they
like what you have to say so now they're
more focused on what they're listening
to rather than trying to learn